This is Michael Spavor, doing what he does
best: bringing foreign athletes to Pyongyang,
to play the North Korean hockey team.
He is a Canadian businessman with a cultural
exchange company based in the northern Chinese
city of Dangdong.
He is also the man behind the unsual friendship
between US basketball star Dennis Rodman and
North Korean leader Kim Jong Un.
Spavor is possibly one of the best-connected
business people in secretive North Korea,
and now, nobody is exactly sure where he is.
Before Beijing confirmed it was investigating
Spavor, Canada's foreign minister confirmed
something was amiss.
We are aware of a Canadian who got in touch
with us because he was being asked questions
by Chinese authorities.
We have not been able to make contact with
him since he let us know about this.
We are working very hard to ascertain his
whereabouts and we have also raised this case
with the Chinese authorities.
We are in touch with his family.
Spavor also uses his base in China to promote
investment in North Korea.
But China now says he is a security risk.